joining us now from the Whitewater
independent council of course and star
Robert Reis all Eisenberg and former
assistant special Watergate prosecutor
John sale cannon Saul are also foxnews
contributors can I want to start with
you
apparently tonight we're getting word
and seeing some video there's another
event going down there in Palm Beach but
it's a celebratory mood should they be
celebrating well I think so because
they're going to be no more indictments
but should also be celebrating because
what we've seen I think is a vindication
of law in the face of politics and media
and the like what we saw today in bill
bars the Attorney General's letter is a
letter that simply is grounded in the
law what we're seeing in reaction from
Capitol Hill is well wait a second we
don't you want to talk about the law and
what the traditions are the Justice
Department that you don't drag people's
names through the mud that you say Mary
Rowe or John Doe hypothetically are
really very bad people but we chose not
to indict them you know the regulations
that came into effect in 1999 after the
experience for the Independent Counsel
statute including the report to Congress
that led to the impeachment of Bill
Clinton Congress that we don't want any
more of that in these regulations I
think are very carefully calibrated to
protect these kinds of basic privacy
interests and the reputational interests
of people who are not being so that's
being waved off tonight though I was
watching the other networks and that
that concern is being waved off saying
Saul would go to you oh that this is no
long standing rule this can be dispensed
with
and Chuck Schumer today came out he
looked like he just lost his best friend
but he came out today and said this the
White House must not be allowed to
interfere in decisions about what parts
of those findings or evidence should be
made public it's imperative for mr. Barr
to make the full report public and
provide its underlying documentation and
findings to Congress now Saul I thought
Muller was the gold standard he two
years the Democrats Muller
the greatest grip and now he does this
report apparently it's not going to give
the Democrats what they want and he'll
like no we want to see her documents
what would this mean for those to be
turned over and is there a legitimate
reason for doing so well I'm for turning
over as much as can be turned over in
fairness and in accordance with with the
law first of all there's no way it's
gonna all be turned over it can't be
under the law turned over right away if
there's any grand jury material in it
that's rule governed by rule 6 e and you
have to have a court order even before
you can turn that over under seal to
Congress we had to get a court order
Leon Jaworski had to get a court order
if there's any grand jury material that
is turned over there has to be a court
order so that's number one but you know
Bill Barr has already said I want to be
transparent I want to turn over as much
as I can I will I will say this I very
much agree with the philosophy that says
you should not smear a person if you're
not going to indict them and I think
this report will follow that principle
except I think that they will it's very
clear that they're fixated the Muller
people have been fixated on the
obstruction question with respect to
president Trump and I think what you
will find is a discussion of efforts to
stymie the Muller team I think it'll be
done in a very dispassionate way I think
they have a different view of President
Trump precisely because he can't be
indicted I think they may go after him a
little bit when they talk about
obstruction I don't think there's a
criminal case for obstruction but I
think they'll talk about it well Adam
Schiff Robert tonight on another network
continued to say be given the fact and
he said given the fact that there's all
this information out there that the
president obstructed the probe we need
all the information so it was like this
report isn't even coming out and it's
not going to reveal you know what we
know is probably not gonna reveal all
that what they wanted it's almost like
they're fantasizing this away and their
commentary tonight and I guess what else
do they do they've spent two years using
words like
treason collaborator with Putin and so
forth and Robert now they're at this
point and I would play a sound bite for
you where Eric's whoa well who's one of
the president's chief critics in
Congress he's talking about moving the
goalposts away from even obstruction to
just a general honor code let's watch I
think the American people want to know
whether this president violated conduct
while whether he violated not only the
law but that honor code that we all
count on Robert what's the honor code
they're talking about I have no I have
absolutely no idea the I mean the only
the only thing that's applicable are the
standards that are that that that are
embodied in the Constitution and you
know I mean guess arguably by
implication the impeachment process
which gets to really only one question
and that is whether there's a violation
of the public trust but I mean you know
in general here beware of efforts to
move the goalposts and which part of
over meaning o V er do the Democrats not
understand I think you know some
perspective is important here it's an
investigation that was conducted over a
period of 22 months it is now concluded
that's the end of it now if Congress
wants to in their infinite wisdom
through House Democrats to conduct their
own investigation that's one thing they
do have subpoena power but the
administration should and would be
correct in doing so resist any efforts
to essentially dump raw data over into
the Congress voluntarily the I do think
that Congress is entitled and I agree
with Saul on this point as to the
president alone the Congress is entitled
to Bob Muller's findings the basis for
why he either decided to bring charges
or not in this instance not to bring
charges that much I think is something
that Congress appropriately in its
oversight capacity is entitled to and
should get and I don't think frankly I
don't think that the administration is
going to resist that and I think
now cooperatively the message that
seemed to be sent today by this letter
is that bill bar in conjunction with rod
Rosen Stein and Bob Muller in these
remaining days and I think this will
happen fairly quickly will be delivering
up those findings to the Congress and in
an appropriate fashion so John I think
they want to pull Muller up to testify
on Capitol Hill maybe bring bill Barr
back again because again it's always the
narrative shifts when they don't get
what they want we have to shift to
another point although there are still
media folks so I think the real
collusion is the media with the DNC with
some people perhaps you know previously
in the FBI who are keeping this thing
going but Chris Hayes last night was
saying this about what he would believe
let's say Muller says look all these
things happen the president act in all
these ways but fundamentally there was
no actual explicit collusion or even
goes further and says you know the
president we exonerate the president
don't know if he can really do that but
do you trust whatever the outcome of
this thing is whatever it says so again
John Muller they built up his
professional impression ilysm and
reputation and a lot of us conservatives
were concerned about the makeup of his
prosecutorial team but the Democrats
built them up into the you can't
couldn't question Bob Muller but now you
can't trust the report when it comes out
where does this leave us today in the
public sphere looking at the
prosecutorial priorities of this country
the Justice Department how did this
period affect the integrity or the trust
I would say that people have in
institutions like the American media
like Laura I can tell you practicing in
this area excuse me that there is a lack
of confidence the confidence has been
shattered but you know Muller has been
held up as a deity everyone is saying
let's wait for the Muller report and I
have never said it's a witch-hunt I
think it's a legit applause a legitimate
investigation but what everybody's
forgetting is he's a prosecutor he's not
judge jury and executioner and the
Devils in the details and we really
don't know what the specifics are
but I think the president is entitled to
have his representatives read it and
prepare a response because prosecutors
are advocates they're not the be-all and
end-all and furthermore kai say one
other thing where I've gotten some
pushback from some of my good friends or
more on the left I've said that during
the course of this period the president
is entitled to the presumption of
innocence and the people come back and
say well that's it a courtroom only in a
courtroom but this is the presidency and
an investigation like this is a cloud
over any president and like any citizen
he's not above the law but he's not
below the law either so why are we not
assuming he didn't do anything wrong
and one other thing in Watergate we our
roadmap which a judge allowed grand jury
material to go to the Congress but we
didn't draw any conclusions we didn't
exonerate and we didn't find anyone
incriminated we just provided citations
and evidence now and let the Congress
make its own decision all right I want
to get all of your reaction to some of
the worst the worst reckless accusations
from our former Intel Chiefs do you
still believe the president could be a
Russian asset I think it's possible I
think that's why we started our
investigation and I'm really anxious to
see where director Muller concludes that
more and more I come to a conclusion
that after the Helsinki performance and
since that I really do wonder whether
the Russians have something on him I
used the term that this is nothing short
of treasonous because it is a betrayal
of the nation he is giving aid and
comfort to the enemy
ken aid and comfort to the enemy
treasonous we had renowned historians
Pulitzer Prize winners saying the same
thing any repercussions here especially
for as we call the deep state folks know
well on the deep state we shall see I do
have great confidence in Michael
Horowitz the Inspector General
we'll see what his report and I know
there have been comments why don't we
see that report but it's very simple I
don't didn't expect Michael Horowitz to
issue any report about possible
wrongdoing within the deeps state until
after bob mower had finished his work I
really think this should be a time but
it's not going to be because we are
living in the age that we're living in
when people say look here is someone Bob
Mahler very respected attacked by the
President attacked pretty vehemently by
the President and who assembled around
him people who clearly were not friends
of the President to put it mildly and
now he is determined that there is no
basis for bringing criminal charges
against the president that's a separate
issue and those close around him in
short when we go back to the may
articulation may 2017 of why he was
appointed the issue is was there
collusion or crimes committed under the
umbrella of collusion and he clearly
must have concluded that there were not
such crimes or the investigation would
still be underway so I think you should
actually be a time of celebration that
our president was not involved in the
campaign in colluding where their
context and communications of course
there were but we've seen final point
we've seen what I've called for a year
now contraindications of collusion in
the two huge indictments that Bob Muller
and his team brought against the Russian
individuals and the Russian
organizations not one word in those very
detailed indictments suggest collusion
and that's tells me a lot so we had Jim
Comey who kind of started this all when
that memo of his the memo to the file
after his conversation with the
president was sent over to his pal at
the New York Times who leaked it to the
New York Times a professor at Columbia
and now he's saying which is interesting
in an op-ed saying that he doesn't care
what the investigation uncovers even
though he started the whole thing so he
kind of saw where this was going in the
end and he had gone on this book tour
you know speaking
you know not favorably obviously toward
the President and clearly wanted this
investigation to happen and now it's
kind of skedaddling away from it
thoughts there well there's a reason
they call him Saint Jim that's all I'll
say he's got kind of a god complex but I
think you you raise an important point I
think it's important to make a
distinction between a former director
Comey and Andrew McCabe and Peter Strock
and the FISA the alleged FISA abuses
that we're going to find out about we we
already know for sure the FISA Court
wasn't told everything that Bruce or
told the DOJ and the FBI there's a
difference between that and between
Muller's operation Muller was asked to
do this and he did it and I know there
are some people that disagree with some
of Muller's tactics and I think he
should have been much more careful in
the team he originally assembled but I'm
unaware of one unethical thing that
anybody on Muller's team did and this
will end up being yes they were too
tough with Roger stone yes I played hard
hardball the court was with Corsi but
nothing they did is was improper under
DOJ rules nothing they did that I'm
aware of is unethical and I think Muller
is a is a great public servant I don't
I've never agreed with him about
everything but he's a man of integrity
and and the irony is this will end up
helping the very man who attacked him
relentlessly President Trump because no
one has ever accused Bob Muller of being
anything other than thorough and he's
done this and he has said there is no
crime connected with collusion yeah and
it's all you're absolutely right and
Robert you can chime in here it is kind
of ironic in the end it looks like that
Muller and his conclusions will benefit
Trump and the Democrats who are praising
Mahler are implicitly criticizing the
Muller findings if they don't get all
the information and they're obviously
skeptical of
idea you didn't find any wrongdoing if
that's what they find or not enough that
rises to the level of criminality at
least they're they're skeptical of
Muller so it's kind of a flip deal here
yeah you can't you can't have it both
ways and by the way even the New York
Times doesn't buy that in an editorial
for tomorrow's paper they say very
pointedly that you know one of the
things that this is shown is that the
rule of law prevails and second which is
what Judge Starr just mentioned and the
second thing is that the president is
very fortunate that he had Bob Muller as
his prosecutor along the way they take a
cheap shot at judge Starr but you know
that just goes to show that a lot of
what's going on here is about you know
partisan political score settling we're
going to get past this and the good news
is the news tonight really is that a
full and fair and complete investigation
was stopped before the end of the
administration yeah that's true
but over the last two years we've had
the nation and this like vice-grip of
anxiety because of this investigation
while it's great to all of us sit here
tonight and say well isn't it wonderful
the rule of oh yeah it is but it's the
quit begs the question should this
investigation have been triggered the
way it was the FISA warrants that were
clearly at the very least misleading as
to the true provenance of that dossier
how the dossier came into being how it
was distributed who paid for it and then
of course you know the president has a
view of the memo the president has a
very never happen right the president
has a very the president has a very
clear position with regard to that and
he may well be proven to be right now
that may we may not know that unless
there's you know further investigation
along the lines that Saul is mentioning
and we may not know that until we have a
better we have the benefit of history I
mean I I've already said that we should
and I think it requires you know not
only release of yeah of what Michael
Horowitz has has been finding along the
way but it's clear already as Saul has
mentioned
that what happened the games that were
played with the FISA Court essentially
is that the department inside the
department there was a real debate about
this it went from the FBI to responsible
officials in Maine justice and the fact
of the matter is they proceeded forward
with an application to the FISA Court
and they did not fully disclose what
they knew which is that the information
was biased and at the same time John
sale there was pressure put on the
process to not indict Hillary Clinton
for for her egregious abuse of
government protocols and classified
information handling so there was
pressure I think on call me and the
crowd of the FBI not to do that not to
pursue that so I think there's a lot
it's and again it's it's wonderful that
it's turned out it looks like the way it
has for the rule of law and all of that
but the fact that this happened to an
individual the president United States
and Lord knows what opportunities we
lost in the process along the way was it
all albatross to this administration who
knows what maybe we would have been able
to do something with Russia that would
have helped the country our security but
you know we certainly didn't but I think
it's well I don't want to let anyone off
here as to how this whole thing started
and commis cute little op-ed
notwithstanding I mean I'm just I think
people has want these questions answered
so this doesn't happen again to anyone
let alone the President of the United
States John that's enough of my soapbox
here well it's it's unfortunate that the
president has to be the victim of what
really are needed reforms in the
criminal justice system I mean it's just
as tragic if it happens to any citizen
as when it happens to the president but
with the president we paid attention to
it but you know with the Muller report
if we'll call it that now it's going to
become the bar summary the Devils in the
details so I think the celebration is a
little premature it's a very good day
for the president but let's see what
happens what details are there and as I
can't
from yeah well John I'll tell it's a
hell of a long wait from the president
was committing treason and was
conspiring his lad Amir Putin against
the American electoral system which is
what we heard for about two plus years
yeah but Laura that's why I said the
person how could the person be who was
supervising rod Rosen Stein this
investigation be a person who was
talking about wearing a wire on the
president thank you so much I didn't
even think about that all right hold on
a second even though Muller is done
though and I think John is right we got
the Southern District of New York
hanging out there correct and Democrats
on Capitol Hill want to launch their own
probes though they I don't think have it
these things don't have anything to do
with Russian election interference so
the Trump Organization security
clearances handling of classified
information the list goes on well there
are any numbers that I could give you of
information that we've obtained our
investigation information that's become
clear from the Special Counsel
investigation that may not be neatly
summed up in a decision or disclosure
that we decided to indict a but not be
the special prosecutor has a specific
mandate to investigate only the possible
only the Russian interference for the
election and possible collusion by the
Trump administration or anybody else
with with with that interference of the
election and only to look at crimes the
Southern District of New York also only
looks at crimes we have to look at a
much broader question I don't see how he
does not have indictments waiting for
him and and they basically are
stiff-arming the house ridiculous
request going on and on and on and for
the most part not responding ken starr
problems on the horizon though because
look there they do have oversight power
although the lot of these matters have
nothing to do with the president's
conduct in office but you know they're
gonna make hay of a lot of this no
there's no question but we've moved to
politics and the 2020 election like the
Iowa caucuses the
the Democratic debates there are a lot
of candidates and so what we're seeing
is fodder for the political process but
happily tonight we're talking more about
law than about politics and we have an
attorney general and bill Barr
who's got to turn square corners and
he's going to go by the law what we're
hearing from Congress's we don't want
you to abide by your regulations we want
you to do something entirely different
we essentially want you to become our
Asian help us in the impeachment process
and as you know Laura that was in fact
the structure of the old Independent
Counsel statute or which several of us
served and happily that's gone away so
it's been a new day and if if Congress
did not like the nature of the reporting
requirements that have been in these
regulations now for twenty years then
they should have held a hearing talk to
an attorney general and said you know we
needed a little bit more information we
think if the occasion arises we need
more information
these are minimalist reporting
requirements and I think that's what
Bill Barr is good now I understand the
other side which is we want maximum
transparency but don't we want maximum
transparency consistent with the rule of
law so we shall see it's all really
quick Southern District of New York the
Democrats are whispering about that
tonight peril ahead for the Trump family
the President himself well keep in mind
anything is possible but keep in mind
that rumors you've heard to the contrary
notwithstanding the Southern District is
actually part of the Department of
Justice they actually report to bill bar
and have to take orders from him so I
think I'm very confident that bill Barr
will not do anything to improperly
interfere with them but he'll make it
very clear that he wants to be kept
abreast of the investigation and I have
great confidence in him as the
department is required to be informed
anyone and this is where the media has
to be vigilant anybody who thinks that
the Southern District of New York should
be used as a stalking horse for the
continuation of the Muller investigation
oh thanks I think
they should have their head examined and
it's going to require supervision and
and to be monitored by the department in
Washington the bill bar was a brilliant
choice and the Democrats trying to call
his integrity at all into question that
tells you all you need to know so tiring
thin already no no it's just not working
what a phenomenal panel all of you thank
you for staying up with us tonight we
really appreciate